VANCOUVER TONIGHT, 6-3
MINNESOTA RIGHT NOW, TWO POINTS
AHEAD OF ST. LOUIS IN THE E  POO
THIS IS WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO WHEN
YOU'RE GREGOR.
LOBALCERS PICKS UP A BIG, KNEW H
KIND OF GOES UNDERNEATH THE ARM
OF JAMES REIMER HERE
KIND OF
CALLE ROSEN BACK
TAKES ILLY
MISSED WIDE.R THAT, IT'S KRUG BS
OU
POINT.
BACK OVER TO COLTON.S
TALKING TO EACH OTHER.
BUCHNEVICHHIM, LEADING THE ST.
LOUIS BLUES.
>> Randy: MELOCHE WILL RIP IT IN
AND AROUND
FAULK'S THERE.
OFF HI TO KNOW,
TRIED TO SET UP BUCHNEVICHY TO
W THAN THE RANGERS
BECAUSE SAMMY BLAIS IS OUT WITH
P OFF THE
BOARDS
TRIED TO
LEDDY WILL REVERSE IS NOW FOR
PERRON AS WE'RE UNDER A MINUTE
IN THE PERIOD.
SCHENN FORT THAT
TIME ACROSS.
SCHENN BACK TO O'REILLY, OFF THE
STICK, RECOVERED BS THFIVE-HOLEE
VETERAN ST. LOUIS GOALTENDER,
WHO REALLY CAME OU
HE DOES.
THOMASLOUIS BLUES.
THOMAS WRAPS IT HARD AROUND AND
TARASENKO GETS IT AND
THE WILD CARD BETWEEN NASHVILLE,
DALLAS, VEGA IT DOAS HIS TEAM
IN IT HERE, BUT I'LL TELL YOU
THIS, COMING OFF THE THE
NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE IN OF WHE
HOME ICE THAT.
DIDN'T GET IT HIGH ENOUGH.
THERE.t: NICE PLAY BY MELOCHE
THAT'S HIS BEST STOP UP WITH RE.
>> Randy: BLUES HAVE SHUT DOWN
THE SHARKSY AND IT'S
BACK OUT
GOOD WORK ALONG THE BOARDS THERE
AND MISS THE